como infecciones intrahospitalarias.
Creo que esto se debe, en parte, a
un problema de construcción ecológica.
Bueno, les voy a contar una historia más sobre este edificio.
Estoy colaborando con Charlie Brown.
Es arquitecto,
y Charlie está muy preocupado por el cambio climático global.
Ha dedicado su vida al diseño sostenible.
Cuando me conoció y se dio cuenta de que podía estudiar
de forma cuantitativa
cómo sus decisiones de diseño
afectaban a la ecología y biología de este edificio,
se entusiasmó mucho, porque aportaba una nueva dimensión a su trabajo.
Pasó de pensar solo en la energía
a empezar a pensar también en la salud.
Ayudó a diseñar algunas de las unidades de tratamiento del aire
en este edificio, y la forma en la que se ventila.
Así que lo primero que les voy a enseñar son
las muestras de aire que tomamos en el exterior del edificio.
Lo que están viendo es la marca de las comunidades bacterianas
en el aire exterior, y cómo varían con el tiempo.
Lo siguiente que les voy a enseñar es lo que pasó
cuando manipulamos experimentalmente las aulas.
Las cerramos por la noche
de forma que no tuvieran ventilación
Muchos edificios funcionan así,
probablemente en su lugar de trabajo,
y las empresas lo hacen para ahorrar costes en la factura de energía.
Lo que descubrimos fue que estas aulas se mantenían relativamente estancadas
hasta el sábado, cuando volvimos a abrir los respiraderos.
Cuando entrábamos a esas aulas,
olían fatal,
y nuestros datos apuntan a que tenía que ver
con la sopa de bacterias transmitidas por aire
de la gente del día anterior.
Comparémoslo con las habitaciones
que se crearon con una estrategia de diseño pasivo
donde el aire entraba desde el exterior por las persianas.
En estas habitaciones, el aire seguía el rastro del aire exterior relativamente bien,
y cuando Charlie vio esto, se emocionó mucho.
Tenía la sensación de haber tomado una buena decisión
en el proceso del diseño,
porque tanto era eficiente en el uso de energía
como era limpio el paisaje de microbios residentes del edificio.
Los ejemplos que les acabo de dar son sobre arquitectura,
pero son relevantes al diseñar cualquier cosa.
Imaginen diseñar con los tipos de microbios que queramos
en un avión
o en un teléfono.
Hay un nuevo microbio, lo acabo de descubrir.
Se llama BLIS, y se ha demostrado
que rechaza agentes patógenos
y proporciona buen aliento.
¿No sería fantástico que todos tuviéramos BLIS en nuestros teléfonos?
Un enfoque de diseño con conciencia,
que voy a llamar diseño bioinformado,
y creo que es posible.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)